[Music]
well well here we are everybody loves a
good team movie and the genre has a lot
of competition you've got John Hughes
classics like The Breakfast Club and
Ferris Bueller's Day Off nineties teen
rom-coms like 10 Things I Hate About You
and cheese all that Richard Linklater's
coming-of-age comedy days to confuse or
recent hits like The Fault in Our Stars
and love Simon you could even throw all
eight Harry Potter movies into the mix
why not but when I searched rancor calm
which everybody knows is the authority
on ranking stuff I'm disappointed to
find that my favorite teen movie doesn't
even crack the top 100 of course I'm
talking about
Kinji Fukasaku x' turn of the millennium
masterpiece battle royale
[Music]
the premise of Battle Royale is really
simple in a dystopian Japan a classroom
of teenagers is chosen every year and
shipped to an island where they have to
fight to the death until only one is
left standing you might recognize this
premise from The Hunger Games books the
first of which came out eight years
after battle royale and nine years after
the book by cast shown Takami
on which it's based this concept is also
the basis for the hugely popular video
game fort night battle royale and its
predecessor player unknowns
battlegrounds which was at least in part
inspired by Fukasaku movie unlike the
Hunger Games Battle Royale is remarkably
contained there is no larger world no
political intrigue plotline the audience
is just dumped into this horrific
situation with the characters and we
experience its shocks as they do and
they are shocks
it's definitely a violent movie but it's
the execution of violence that makes
battle royale so great and this should
come as no surprise though I didn't know
this when I first saw the movie at
summer camp
age 16 battle royale is the final film
of Japanese auteur
Kinji Fukasaku he made this incredibly
vigorous film about teenagers at age 70
which is amazing but by then Fukasaku
was a master a criminally
underappreciated master of Japanese and
world cinema he made his mark on the
industry in the 1970s with a
breathtaking series of films about
Japanese gangsters the Yakuza in the
chaos after world war ii unlike the more
traditional Yakuza films Fukasaku x'
movies have a wild manic energy to them
the camerawork is designed to throw you
into the action it's a thrilling
disorienting experience to watch them
and Fukasaku x' message in those films
comes through loud and clear in a
society decimated by war friendship
camaraderie even the famous codes of
honor of the Yakuza only stretched so
far
it was truly every man for himself and
if someone could get an advantage by
betraying his friend he was more likely
to do it than not Fukasaku is films the
honorable ones are often the first to be
killed
well the nobody home anymore Gotti I
mean he killed on Joe you think I'm not
old enough to be on a campus ha ha ha a
tonight in Battle Royale
the same philosophy holds in the chaos
of the game the speed at which friends
turned to enemies can give you whiplash
and the violence like the violence of
the Yakuza films is sudden devastating
as a viewer it's like you're one of the
students it all comes so fast at the
beginning that you just want to pause
and get a grip on things but there's no
time for that the ones who trust too
liberally are the ones who get killed
first it may seem like Battle Royale is
a fable of nihilism with mindless brutal
killing doled out to anyone and everyone
but the violence in Fukasaku is vision
has a purpose like all great team movies
Battle Royale is really about friendship
that may be a little hard to see but
Fukasaku is interested in what
friendship really means when the gloves
are off in the most barbaric
circumstances what does human connection
mean in the context of humanity's
capacity for unspeakable violence at
that time unspeakable violence was very
much alive in the memory of the older
generation in Japan it tested them in
ways that the younger generation
couldn't begin to understand and this is
what life was like for Fukasaku himself
when he was 15 the same age as the
students in the film in the movie it's
almost as if the older generation
represented by a teacher devises the
game as a way to communicate their
experiences with the youth and it's
almost as if Fukasaku made the film for
the same reason Battle Royale is
interested in the kind of friendship
that can't be explored at a high school
its friendship tainted by a deeply cruel
world but it's all the more poignant
when it persists in spite of that fact
oh my god oh
Sakai Japan kakuhen ah
[Music]
Fukasaku is last movie is a lot of
things it's blackly comical it's scary
it's a naked look at humanity and it's a
gripping piece of balls-to-the-wall
entertainment directed by a man with a
lifetime of skill and experience it's a
team movie and it deserves to be
considered with the very best of that
genre hey everybody thank you so much
for watching this episode was brought to
you by Skillshare which is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 21,000 classes and everything
from graphic design and film editing to
finance and IT security you know what I
learned Photoshop I learned it through a
weird mishmash of disconnected YouTube
videos and I think the process would
have gone a lot faster and better if
there was a class dedicated to teaching
me everything that program could do in a
more systematic way
that's what Skillshare offers learning
new skills is really valuable to me
because whenever I learn a new skill
it's like a bunch of new ideas are
unlocked in my head I think what can I
do with this and that always always
helps me with writer's block a premium
membership begins around ten dollars a
month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 500 people to sign
up using the link in the description get
their first two months for free in those
two months you can easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby or
business more importantly the skills you
learn will help give you ideas for what
that business or art project could be
definitely try it out thanks guys I'll
see you next time